Hey YouTube We Still Need your Help to win a Streamy award We Need you to go to twitter and tweet the hashtag
#TKORForStreamys
We Need your vote it's Very important Because your vote might be the one that tips us over and Helps us win huh?
That is not the scenario i would have predicted to see?
Hey What's up Guys welcome back for another
epic day of
Experimenting i Brought You outside Today Where i've Got a 6 Gallon Gasoline Fuel can as Well as an Electric Hot Plate Kind of Seems
A little Bit Random but it'll make sense in Just a minute
Now the request for our experiment Today
came Out of The comments from mix monwa3at who got
235 Thumbs Ups for Asking The question What happens when you boil Gasoline
Now Let's start off This Project Today by taking Just a Second to talk about What
Gasoline Actually is Now you may Remember the story that back When i was 21 Years old i used to work on the oil rigs?
Drilling Holes into the Ground and extracting crude oil where it could Be shipped off and Refined into products Like Gasoline
Now iF you've ever pulled Up to the gas station You probably noticed different octane Ratings for the Fuel you got regular and you've Got
Premium and What Those Numbers are telling you is how much compression that Liquid can take before self-igniting
Now if you ever want to try storing Gasoline it's important that You use containers that Comply with the regulations of the EPA
Gasoline Is a Very volatile Liquid and Depending on The temperature and pressure
It may cause the container you have It stored into to erode or
Explode Even this six Gallon container that is compliant with the EPA you can See how much pressure is built Up inside
This Thing Is Bulging and Ready to burst There's a Lot of pressure sitting in there right Now
So the purpose of Today's Experiment is to see what will Happen if we Put Gasoline in an open container on a hot plate and
Let It Boil. Will The Gasoline Actually boil at All or Will it Just vaporize into the air? and if It Does Start Boiling Will Those
Bubbles Foam Up and Froth Over and spill Over in the hot plate itself and is IT possible for Gasoline to actually get hot enough
To self ignite we're answering Those three questions in this video today
All right so quick update These Nozzles are much more Trouble Than They're worth we're Just gonna scrap them and pour Directly from the container
That Should Be more Than enough
So here we are Guys Have Just Transferred the Gasoline from a Jerrycan into this Pyrex Glass
This can Hold about Two Cups Right Now i've Got Leveled about a cup and a Half
Now it's important to note That Right Now we're being Very Careful not to have any open flames Because obviously The vapor That's coming off
This Right Now is
Extremely Flammable and we Don't want This Thing to ignite prematurely Now we're using Pyrex for This first experiment as a Back-up Plan I'm gonna
Stick a Pot Down underneath It so that Way iF the Glass cracks we'll Be Able to contain the gasoline in the pot Without it
Spilling Over onto the Burner all right about to Turn it on the starting temperature right Now is surprisingly only about
13.7 Celsius When i look at The Actual hot plate itself some of The Edges we're showing 40 degrees Celsius There's a Dramatic difference i
Think That's from Keeping This in cold storage Yep That's definitely cold So Let's Turn the heat on let 'em rip and
Let'S see what happens
It has Been about 10 minutes i Just came back to check and you can Always see some white fumes are coming off i see
Little Bubbles coming From The bottom of the gasoline i don't see it boiling yet but When i measure the temperature it's showing about
58 Degrees
Celsius that has Warmed Up quite a Bit from where it Was 10 minutes Ago so we let this Thing Run another five to 10
Minutes and we'll Check in on them Dang That's increasing fast
so at 60 degrees Celsius i
Think of This Stuff Explodes in Our face accidentally we'll Just remember to stop drop and roll Should solve all our problems Right
Look At That if you look down here you can Actually see it's bubbling from the bottom
we did not even make it to 5 minutes Guys i Just Checked in on this and it's Actually bubbling if you look at the
Surface You can See bubbles coming Up to the top and collecting Measuring the temperature
I'm showing we're at about 82 degrees Celsius so this is actually Boiling
Under the Boiling Point of Water so Gasoline Will boil and it will boil before Water Does That's interesting so now the question is how hot
Can We Actually Get This if We Leave This on the burner Plate how hot will that Liquid get before It either Burst into flames
or Boils off completely
Gasoline Is showing Over a Hundred and Forty five degrees Celsius
It's like Two Hundred and Eighty degrees Fahrenheit Now it's really Really hot look at all The vapor That's coming off it'S a Tremendous amount
At This point i'm Thinking That Whole Thing is gonna boil completely Dry Without Igniting at All
Which is Kind of surprising i Mean i thought maybe It would Get hot enough to light into flames but
Without an open source of Flames
Apparently i'd have to get quite a Bit hotter it almost Looks like The Gasoline itself is getting
Concentrated as well It's not quite as Clear as It used to be it's a lot more of a Darker Yellowish orange
So something in there is obviously getting concentrated Out That's amazing That's almost completely gone
It's very Very Hot Very hot to the touch Whew
Very hot to the touch I'm Just gonna Let this boil down
completely Because i want to see as it gets Toward The bottom is It going to accelerate and Actually Burst into flames at All
All right we're on the home stretch you can see all the vapor coming Out Now this is happening Very quickly i should Probably Get
a reading about a Hundred and Eighty degrees Celsius
370 degrees Fahrenheit That's Pretty Dang Hot Obviously That's about as hot as It can Get on its own so what if we Let This
Will it just Boil or Will Burst into flames That is our next experiment
okay so look at That There's some Kind of interesting residue at The bottom there some Kind of a
Brownish motor Oily Looking Stuff See that This is Actually so hot Right Now i'm having trouble Hanging on to it
Co2 fire extinguisher i value my Skin so we're bringing out the big guns for Safety
That Should Be Good enough
for This One we're gonna Get Crazy and Try something Little Bit different i'm gonna pull the pot Out of the scenario and put the
pirates Directly Onto The Burner Itself Actually Give It a Little Bit more Heat
We're Just gonna give that a Few more Minutes to heat Up to maximum then we're gonna take a small
Cup of Gasoline and Pour it Directly in the Center Good idea Bad idea we're about. To find out oh my gosh?
Now They took That pot off the
temperature's Going Up dramatically
640 Fahrenheit and the Glass we're already Up to 430 That's cool i
Wonder if This will Work after All
Putting the Glass Directly on the Burner is making a Dramatic difference to how much Heat is Actually going into the glass
I think the Pot Was acting as a Heat Sink and deflecting some of That off so we're gonna bring This Thing up till it's
about 250 degrees Celsius Which is
Extremely Hot i think we're gonna Throw The Gasoline in before i pour this Thing i'm gonna do one Final Check
so i'm showing Pretty close to 300 degrees Celsius Which is over
550 degrees Fahrenheit This is absolutely Ridiculous
This Setup Right Now is actually hotter Than The inside of your Oven
Can Actually Get so if this Does not ignite without a flame i'm gonna Actually Feel a lot Safer about Handling Gasoline
Moment of Truth Here we Go now i'm Just gonna Kind of stand off
To the side here in case something Goes Terribly wrong I'M gonna Dump It all in one Go in three two one. Oh?
and It Broke the Glass
That Was not Actually The Reaction i was Expecting i was Thinking maybe It Would Go up in flames maybe i Just sitting there boil
but It Actually
Cracked The Pyrex Spilled Out Over the Burner all Over the cement no sign of Flames Whatsoever Just a Lot of Broken Glass
Huh okay so here comes the liquid you can see It coming down from the top
Half of It Goes in container the other Half Kind of Splashes Out on the burner and all over the pavement
You can Actually See the Gasoline inside the container like erupting Shooting back Up out of the top and
There Goes the side of the Glass cracking
Obviously some Kind of an issue with Thermal shock the two extremes meeting cold Gasoline in a Very hot Glass container so if that didn't
Light Off i don't know What Would obviously at some point it is gonna be a surface hot enough to ignite the Gasoline but That's
Gonna Be extreme temperatures Beyond anything That we can Generate using in the Oven or an Electric Burner and That's Good news i do Feel
Like We Have to have some Kind of fire though so i'm going to take This Residual over here and light it off
Most of its evaporated i Guess There's a Little Bit of a flame There but it's hard to see in the Daylight
We'd Start off This Experiment Today to see Exactly What Would Happen if we Put Gasoline on a hot Burner and raise The temperature quickly
The first Thing We've Observed is the Gasoline warmed up and Began to boil
But The bubbles did Not Turn into a frothy foam and spill Over the edge Instead They Just Popped in vaporize into the air
After about 15 to 20 minutes we noticed most of The Gasoline had Vaporized off but The temperature never Actually rose high enough for those
Vapors To self ignite the reason is because all the Energy going to the Gasoline to vaporize
It Kept The Liquid at a Very constant temperature somewhere around 160 degrees Celsius
When all that gas Vaporized out of the container we decided to Try a Second experiment to see if we could Heat the container up
Even Hotter And pour the Gasoline into that The question being What a container that Was twice as hot as the boiling point of Gasoline
Get It to auto Ignite but in pouring the Gasoline into the container What we found was rather Than the gas
Igniting The Glass container Actually Broke Now of course Glass Isn't the best Material to use
But We Also Saw That as The Gasoline spilled Down over the Extremely hot Burner no reaction Happened nothing Lit on fire
It Just Spilled Out onto the ground and Began to vaporize in the atmosphere so we grabbed a blowtorch and tried to light off the
rest
Based on the results of This experiment I'm a Lot more Confident Working with Gasoline Now now obviously if you got a surface hot enough
You Could Get The Gasoline to ignite back When i was playing with My solar scorcher in concrete
I poured Gasoline onto the concrete and that Was hot enough to light the Gasoline Vapors off Just With Power of the sun so if
Concentrated Sunlight Will Do That I'M sure There's a temperature where we can Get Gasoline to flash into ignition However
Using The Kind of Equipment Like Ovens Stoves and Electric Burners That We Have Around the house it's not Likely to happen and That's Good
News
Well There you have it Guys We Have Successfully Answered the question What happens when you boil?
Gasoline and a Big thanks to you mix manhua 3ad for putting this Suggestion down in the comments and Go check your YouTube inbox Because
we're sending You 25 bucks
Now quick disclaimer This is not an experiment i want you to try at home Playing with Gasoline is Extremely Dangerous and if It gets
on your skin
you May Never look the same for the rest of Your life for This experiment we had Safety protocols in place a Giant Carbon dioxide
fire extinguisher we were using an Electric Burner and no open Sources of Ignition
replicating This Kind Of Experiment on top of an open flame like a fire pit for Example would Yield Much different Results That's not something
I recommend trying at home so thanks for Joining Us for this experiment Guys i'll be looking for you the next one talk to you
Then
and That My Friends is how you clean Gasoline off Your Driveway
we're almost Out of time for the streamys of the votes are almost in so right Now
Jump Over Twitter Cast Your vote Tko our four streamys we'd love to win an award
Thank you in Advance Because That one vote That tips the balance into our favor It Helps us win Just might be Yours